تعد الطاقة النووية مصدرًا مثيرًا للجدل للطاقة ، حيث أثارت
كارثة فوكوشيما اليابانية في عام
2011 مخاوف تتعلق بالسلامة ، وفي
السنوات الأخيرة ، ابتعدت العديد من الدول
عنها
مشيرة إلى كل من القضايا البيئية
والتكلفة المالية ، لكن المدافعين عنها يقولون
إن لديها أوراق اعتماد صديقة للبيئة ، وبصمة الكربون الخاصة بها
أصغر بكثير من الطاقة الأخرى.
مصادر الآن
، أصبحت الإمارات العربية المتحدة أول
دولة عربية تراهن عليها بشكل كبير ، وعادةً ما
تجد محطات طاقة نووية في
البلدان ذات الموارد الشحيحة
التي لا تمتلك طاقة. أوروبا الولايات المتحدة والصين
والهند تختار مستوردي الطاقة ،
فلماذا تكون هنا لأنهم  لا يريدون
استخدام مواردهم الخاصة وموارد النفط والغاز ،
فهم أفضل حالًا في
توليد الطاقة بشيء آخر
مثل المحطة النووية ثم
أخذ النفط والغاز وبيعهما
وأعتقد أن هذه استراتيجية
قم بالتنويع بعد ساعتين غرب أبو
ظبي
وستجد محطة البركة النووية بالقرب
من الحدود السعودية  موقع ضخم به أربعة
مفاعلات وعندما يعمل بكامل طاقته
سنوفر ربع احتياجات الدولة من الطاقة ،
يعد هذا أحد أكبر
المنشآت التجارية وهذه المنشأة التي
بنتها الدولة مصدر الطاقة هذا
سيوفر خمسة وعشرين بالمائة من
الكهرباء للأمة  ما هو الفراغ الذي ينبعث منه
21 مليون طن من انبعاثات ثاني أكسيد الكربون
سنويًا بحيث
يغير بشكل كبير بصمة
من إزالة الكربون من ثاني أكسيد
الكربون بطريقة ما ،
لكنه يأتي بسعر باهظ يصل
إلى 24 مليار دولار ، لماذا يتم
تطوير الطاقة النووية عندما  تمتلك دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة
وفرة من النفط ، وقد انخفضت تكلفة
تطوير الطاقة الشمسية وطاقة الرياح
بشكل كبير خلال السنوات القليلة
الماضية
، حيث تم استخدام النفط والوقود الأحفوري على مدار
أربعة عقود ، وتستخدمه الصناعات الهيدروكربونية
في كل مكان في
حياتنا.
اعتدنا أن نستخدمه
في حالة الاحتراق فقط من أجل الضراوة ،
نحتاج إلى تجديد الطاقة النووية نحتاج
إلى الوقود الأحفوري لإنشاء
سلة من الطاقة  مرنًا
من وجهة نظر أمن الطاقة
وأيضًا من وجهة النظر الاقتصادية الآن في
غضون أسابيع قليلة ، من المتوقع أن تقوم الإمارات العربية المتحدة
بتشغيل أول محطة طاقة نووية تجارية في العالم العربي ،
مناطق جون تيفت سي إن إن